my mom will kill me for telling this
because my are our family doctors and I
he'd been our family my doctor since I
was a child and laughter but I went as
an adult because I was there's something
wrong with my bum when you said bum you
looked at me directly in the eyes there
was something there was something wrong
with my I was I said there's this thing
wrong with my firm and he went okay and
I went so which is eight here as well
it'll probably be all right I'd like you
to just if you could make me feel better
about if I feel better than it will be
all right and he went it it'll probably
clear itself up when I said yeah but
it's the only way I could be sure honey
when you want me to put my finger up
there don't ya
it's not magically nice
twenty-five years later you forget
opened the door Oh went in and the
lights flipped on but it wasn't my
family who are in the room it was three
fully grown naked men and a woman on the
bed